we worked really really hard i worked  really really hard to try and bring  you know a good closure to a character  not only with their relationship but  eve's own kind of existential journey  because she's very much changed by the  beginning of of season four and  continues to change by  until the finale what are you doing i'm  trying to show you i've changed if you'd  really changed  you wouldn't have come here uh if you'd  really changed you wouldn't have let me  there's still the electricity oh come on  yes and even more because  there's a certain expectation that i  hope that we fulfill  do you know that fable about the  scorpion and the frog they hook up  they both die  because the scorpion can't change its  nature  this is the last time that you're going  to see them together  so  come later on in the season  you're going to see them in situations  that they never thought they would be in  together